in Hedwig it was part of the the show is
that you go into the audience and you
kiss audience members because you very
polite term I'm more like putting my
head inside their mouth basically I
basically compute molesty of my let's
molest ticket paying audiences okay so
you would go into the crowd and these
are primarily men how would you pick
which guy you were gonna do because if
you pick the wrong guy it could be it
could not go well not go well for the
most part people were kind of I think
people who know the show if you're
familiar with the show it's a very
rambunctious sort of crew I think it's
got a large following people know what
they're getting into for the nice part
whether it comes through the show so I
would tend to pick the people who I
assume didn't know what was going on for
the you know for the comedy for myself
and for everybody else watching the show
so I would try and target the most
conservative looking straight boys
because I that's just more fun so one
night I remember going for this one dude
and I came over telling this story this
I'm just giving fodder for people to
make fun of me okay that's that's what
we're here for yeah
so after the show this guy who I
basically roughed up quite a bit he had
makeup on him and everything he came
back he would you like kissed him all
over his face
all all up and everywhere that I could
possibly reach in the span of time that
I had the guy just had lipstick all in
glitter all over him and afterwards he
came backstage with somebody who knew
somebody from the show and he was a good
sport about and he seemed very genteel
and sort of ho-hum like gee like that
was crazy and on the way out me being
pleased with myself for giving a
rollicking good time to a conservative
young man right a couple comes in
afterwards and they go do you know that
was no that's her favorite gay porn star
I'm sorry so this guy was was putting on
airs he's clearly seen much more than I
ever have and h1i
shoutout to that young man but yeah he
was about it okay he's very well liked
and listen if I was gonna if I only went
for the best
you